how often have you found yourself in
this situation
[Music]
I quit I quit I quit I quit is your team
always terrible oh you guys are trying
listen to me
do you constantly have to drag the
lifeless corpses of your teammates over
the Finish Line you're like what
[Music]
do anything either bro well it's time we
got to the bottom of this why does your
team always suck is it actually their
faults are you to blame or is there
someone else entirely making you lose
over and over well what if I told you
that the answer to that question is
actually
all of the above
[Applause]
okay so before we start sounding off
about what a bunch of ranked
you are I want to let you all know that
we have merch head over to
shop.thescore.com and check out our
Esports collection we have tons of cool
original designs in awesome colorways I
wear them all the time they're great
okay so it's no secret that teamwork is
key to basically every major Esports
there's an old saying in team sports you
win as a team and you lose as a team
there's no iron team
and Kobe said I know but there's an in
me in that
while nobody gets up set sharing the
glory
win
sing definitely
I feel like it's first chance to be with
team and quality for one million dollar
major
and then they start losing because maybe
of me because I didn't hit my shots I
feel so sad hell you don't have to be
the best player on the planet to know
the pain of questioning what went wrong
in a match or the rage that comes with
realizing
that it was probably your teammate's
fault
go right go right right left right and
left there's only two
listen listen how old are you Silva how
old are you there's white there's lift
you learn that in kindergarten
except how often is it that the people
you're playing with are actually the
problem well to answer that question we
first have to take a look at how games
determine who gets paired up with whom
yes kids that's right the time has come
to talk about rank
where is it where is it man I
Disappeared
now what each game calls each level
really makes no difference you master
Guardian Crusader you the basic idea
behind these ratings is pretty much the
same across the board games will split
up players according to their skill
level and ensure or do their best to
ensure that they play with people in a
similar skill bracket now every game has
its own way of determining what your
rank should be it could be your in-game
stats number of wins versus law losses
how many games you've played or likely
some silly imperfect combination of all
of those things and more generally
speaking the highest percentage of
players are grouped somewhere towards
the bottom of the pile with each
subsequent tier shrinking the pool of
your skill peers to fewer and fewer
people after all there are only so many
god-tier gamers players of the same rank
get put into teams that play against
other teams of similarly ranked players
and the rationale for having these
systems is fairly obvious you don't want
someone who just picked up a game to go
up against somebody who's been playing
it for years it's boring for the veteran
and unfair to the Newbie
all right
it's so sweaty
so naturally if you were in the lower
ranks then chances are your teammates
are as well so in that sense it could be
their fault that you're losing since
they are still learning the game
hopefully as you get better you get
teamed with people who are also better
and then you can stop blaming them for
the team's failures and then of course
once you reach a moderately High ELO you
can start accusing your teammates of
being boosted since surely they're piss
poor mechanics cannot have earned them a
spot in their current rank but of course
not every single teammate you have can
afford to be a boosted animal
unfortunately if it were that simple we
wouldn't be here in the first place and
I did say the beginning that we were
gonna have to explore several
possibilities one of which being that it
might be you who's tanking your games
the more psychologically significant
something is to you the more a part of
your identity so if someone if if you're
consistently losing or if you're not a
rank at a rank that you believe you
should be at or that you imagine that
you should be at then you're going to
reject
possible evidence or possible arguments
that actually it's you know you're not
as good as you think you are essentially
if Esports is like your whole
personality taking responsibility for
your mistakes can destroy your sense of
self so in order to protect us our minds
shift the blame for losing games to
other people how many times have you
found yourself saying I got mine in CS
go or blaming the jungler in League of
Legends after dying three times in three
minutes which if you think about it sort
of goes against the whole ethos of Team
based gameplay sure if you played well
that's great but an L is an l no matter
how outstanding your performance may
have been still on a surface level if
your individual stats are good in a
match that your team just lost it is a
very easy easy to fall into the Trap of
thinking that it is your teammates that
suck the reason why people are like you
know I'm in what rank you I'm silver but
not really I'm actually probably
platinum or Diamond you know that's it
honestly it just comes down to eager a
good example of this in action is League
of Legends dardoch back in his prime the
N A jungler was Notorious for being a
teammate from Hell sorry doctors at my
team I don't care if he's getting
annoying to play with a good triple
killing just some types of question
marks question marks and then says
instead of trying to win or instead of
trying to recover like there's no
talking about what we should do
afterwards they're still talking about
how they're going to win this game
there's no talking about how we're going
to team fight like you're just jungling
even though dardoch was lauded as one of
the best junglers ever to come out of
North America he's
uncooperative attitude
attits or less cost him his career
perhaps if dardoch had merely
internalized the old adage there's no I
in team we could have still been
enjoying plays like these gonna be taken
low however the gargoyle Stone play will
keep him healthy enough bullet time goes
out but bio Frost walks out of the way
stunt is going to be killed by Bjergsen
bio Frost continues there it is grabs a
lot of damage a lot of CC and that's all
they needed a double kill for the
jungler a triple kill and an ace for TSM
and if you think the mind is a one-trick
pony when it comes to self-preservation
boy do I have news for you have you ever
heard of the Dunning Krueger effect it's
kind of two sides to it but the side
most relevant here is a tendency for
um people who have lower skill or
knowledge in a domain to overestimate
their own ability right because they
don't know what they don't know and
bundled right into overestimating
yourself is the inclination to either
ignore advice from people who might
actually be able to help your whole team
clinch the round or even worse straight
up on them uh mugawara can you
throw your grenade on on this wall right
here
just throw your EMP grenade
okay we're done someone starts arguing
about someone giving them advice I just
think to myself I wonder how old these
guys are like if if they're on there
like 18 you know it's whatever you know
like when I was a kid I was pretty
stubborn so
um it's something they learn over time
and I think the younger players there's
it's 50 50 with and not even it's like
20 of them actually listen to advice 80
they just kind of do their thing because
they think they're the best at it which
is fines confidence but let's pretend
for a second that you're someone who
knows all about the games your mind
plays that you'd never let unconscious
biases affect your judgment and you rely
strictly on facts when it comes to
blaming your team for being complete and
utter failures oh my
yeah
Dude where's my bro what like come on
where's my team let me tell you right
now that sometimes what you perceive as
facts
are actually kind of but I'm
gonna let Colton take this one because
if I have to talk about League of
Legends
ranked ladder I am gonna lose it
and now the guy who actually knows what
he's talking about as a man of science I
love to look at numbers and quantify
things and when my ranked teammates
complain about my KDA they also seem to
be pretty obsessed with the numbers
thankfully every competitive game under
the sun is happy to give me plenty of
stats at the end of the game to show me
exactly what my teammates were up to but
without proper context these numbers can
also become an Unstoppable Catalyst
fueling your negative views about your
teammates in fps titles for example a
player's KDA can often be at least a
Fairly reliable indicator of their skill
if you're getting tons of kills and not
dying a whole lot Ozark you're making
some decent decisions and know what
you're doing especially if this ratio is
averaged over a bunch of games but
there's always more to these competitive
games than just kills and deaths if
you're bot later in a league game is 3-0
but they just chill in Lane while the
rest of you die and lose the game are
they really any good at legal Legends
and to further prove my point this guy
exists oh Tactical
now he's gonna hit the tower watch
oh no he's gonna go for more
oh the proudest call Tech no way to get
a triple no no oh my
even though the Baus literally got
banned for feeding he also held the rank
of Challenger at one point which is the
highest rank in League of Legends for
those blessed enough not to know but of
course most of us aren't the Baus our
KDA Ebbs and flows and good games and
bad games tend to balance themselves out
which is exactly what Riot or any other
rank Dev for that matter wants winning
feels good and losing sucks if the
ranked experience is balanced in such a
way that you get just enough warm
fuzzies from seeing that shiny rank go
up then you're more likely to keep
playing but all of these stats this
illusion of total information can start
to play into those psychological traps
that Dimitri mentioned earlier from a
distance you're able to lump together
games where you did well forget all
about the bad games and just focus on
the times where your stats looked good
and your teammates didn't and we're all
susceptible to this none of us wants to
think we're bad at the video games we
play but that mindset can be the very
thing that's keeping you from getting
any better whether whether you want to
rank up in CS or finally win a game of
online chess getting better means you
need to look objectively at your
gameplay the good and the bad this is
where a coach or even just a similarly
skilled friend can be invaluable they
can help shift your focus away from
stats and shiny ranks towards looking at
your game objectively as a whole and
that was the guy who actually knows what
he's talking about so there you go
competitive ranking systems are
basically designed to prey on your
deepest insecurities Riot and every
other developer who designs a rank
ladder basically wants you to think that
your teammates are the problem people
love assigning labels to themselves
there if they can neatly say I'm Diamond
I'm you know Grandmaster and Global
Elite that kind of thing then that is a
really really nice quantifiable way of
saying I'm good at the game whereas
conversely if you're you know bronze
um or silver or something like that you
know that's one unifiable way of saying
you're not the best right like you're in
the bottom thirty percent or in the
bottom 50 so yeah by quantifying that
you're very much so kind of uh relating
that back to someone's identity making
that a part of their identity so
especially if someone uh perceives
themselves as skilled at a game and the
rank that they received is that at odds
with their self-perception that's going
to cause some tension there because Halo
sucks I don't care it's terrible old
people only play these disgusting meta
Champs or the most broken you guys play
whatever you want which that's how it
should be that tension by the way is
what keeps you playing you want to see
the fancy ranked badge get fancier or
see your rank numbers go up and you'll
immediately queue up for another game
just to make it happen that's how these
companies get you but don't worry there
may be hope for you yet because you're
more likely to have this tension at
lower levels right like people at the
higher levels aren't bronze they're
gonna be a rank that's a little bit more
flattering and can firms their own
self-assessment of having high skill so
what have we learn today well I think
it's that all of us are at least a
little susceptible to wishful thinking
nobody wants to feel like a loser and if
blaming your teammates for losing games
that matter to you can spare you from
experiencing that icky feeling you'll do
it without even realizing why you're
doing it this is literally how we as
humans are wired we've also learned that
at the end of the day game developers
are businesses and if they can
capitalize on your desire to be good at
something you love to make some money
they probably will even if that means
creating and sustaining the toxic
Cesspool that is the League of Legends
ranked experience now apparently
everybody that starts a new account has
played this game and is a god at this
game because their attitude is
absolutely disgusting you put with this
now Caitlyn Sarah has an ocean dragon go
in you stupid
terrible these games are designed to
make you obsessed with rank so that you
keep playing and being obsessed with how
much your teammates suck isn't a bug of
this system it's a feature and look
sometimes yes your teammates are
actually the problem no oh you went by
yourself
please please chicken coop Chicken Coop
chicken poop toots where do you play
have you ever played the snap before but
most of the time all you need is a
little bit of patience for your fellow
flawed humans and if you're having
trouble with that just remember that
someday some game it'll be you who's the
teammate that sucks
and it won't actually be your fault
either oh did Brown's copper LOL you're
so bad little I'm an actual master plan
and it's so sad to see that Enchanted
I've been playing Call of Duty for 14
years and now I have to play against
somebody who's also been playing for 14
years
it's funny man it's so great I don't
know
watch I'm gonna go that's gonna be the
end more and I'm gonna get on by a
bunch of console out there